hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm today we're down for the
2015 London chest classic our opponents
are two of the heavyweights why it's
going to be played by nakamura his
opponent playing the black piece is
gonna be Vichy an on former world
champion Nakamura is in second place in
the entire grand chest tour this is the
third leg the London chess classic to
the Norway in the seen field cup and
knowing that top love in first place has
kind of faltered lost two of the first
three rounds Nakamura is in prime
position if he can have a good
tournament here it's actually win this
entire thing his opponent though in
sixth place is one of the most dangerous
players in the world it's never a good
sign when division on is facing off
against table he's just really really
difficult to play against always puts
you in tough situations but we'll go
ahead and get into it starts out with
pawn to d4 I'm not here to f6 9 f3 pawn
to e6 pawn c4 upon d5 pawn to g3 getting
into the Catalan opening now there's two
variations that black can kind of get
into we can do the open candle an
opening with pawn taking here on c4
later looking to control that with pawn
here to b5 just looking to kind of
dominate the Queen side of the board
it's gonna be difficult to kind of hold
on to this pawn the entire game but kind
of hold on to it as much as possible
with pawn here to b5 instead an on
decides to go ahead and elect for the
closed kattiline opening with bishop
here to e7 wants to hold on to this pawn
here on d5 his central squares as long
as possible after B Bishop to G to
castle on the Kings side and then Queen
here to c2 Ananta now plays pawn to c5
we see castle on the King side and then
pawn taking here on d4 you're just
usually going to see the pawn take on d4
compared to the pawn taking here on c4
pawn captures Bishop captures Queen
comes up here to see for black just
usually wants to kind of hold on to his
central squares both on e6 and d5 so
it's just much more common it's not the
worst thing ever to go ahead and take
the other way but we do see vision on go
with what's more common pawn taking here
on d4 now after the knight captures on
Addie forbus he queen out here to b6
just putting a little pressure on the
center of the board a rook over here to
d1 protecting this night and then Knight
see 6 now this knight on d4 is not doing
too much this nice on c6 is controlling
the center of the board so Nakamura just
decides to go ahead and exchange off
material and the Queen takes here on c6
now personally I'm more of a fan of just
taking with the pawn here on c6 kind of
opens up the door for my LightSquared
bishop the close Catalan opening is
typically a cramped position for black
early on and so anything you can do to
kind of alleviate some of that tension
and pressure is always nice so this move
I feel like gives some black a little
opportunity to give his life
spearfishermen volumes to the game you
know Knight to c3 is a pretty common
move we see a bishop here - a6 attacking
this pawn right here this is completely
fine to me a lot of his piece is kind of
controlling the stern of the board
he has a double bishop pair so he can
maybe get that over here if he wants to
control all these diagonals that's fine
as well but he took with this Queen
that's definitely not bad at all I just
like I don't even have to worry about
anymore protection on this pawn d5 if I
already have another pawn there as well
but it takes with his queen on c6 Bishop
out here to g5 as we said before since
Nakamura doesn't have his pawn to e3
first he goes dark square Bishop out
involved into the action where it's a
little bit more difficult for a vision
on since he has kind of this pawn
cheney's light to her bishop it's a
little bit more blocked ins not doing
too much right now pawn here to h6 we do
see exchange off the board Nakamura
decided you know dark square bishop
especially in these type of openings
it's not going to do as much as the
light squared bishop and so he decides
okay that a central night here on f6 was
doing more than I wanted to do
definitely more than that Irish where
Bishop decides to go ahead and exchange
off the board now black does have a
double Bishop here so he's going to be
looking to open up the board a little
bit really use both of these bishops to
their fullest potential is gonna have to
wait a little while since his life
squared bishop is not involved into the
action yet now Knight here to a3
protecting this pawn on a c4
Bishop here to a d7 we're over here to
be one protecting the pawn here on b2
and then we're over here to a CH so
vision on and nakamora both completed
development but really want to get this
bishop here to d7 to swing over the rook
to see aids really controlling the
semi-open file is always nice for black
and whites kind of in a tough
but he actually needs to move his queen
and the reason for that is the knight is
it can't really move it can't come to B
1 or C 2 for obvious reasons can't come
to seats 4 because there's a piece there
but the knight really can't even come to
be 5 because the Queen could just take
and if the pawn takes then the Richards
come come down here to see to intake and
this you would hand is if there's any
other move besides kind of moving this
Queen let's say pawn here to b3 which
seems on the surface kind of as nice
little move a little projection for this
pawn here on c4 then this Queen to d6 is
pretty deadly it's attacking this night
here on a3 and there's no real good
place for this night to go if it comes
up here to Knight to b5 then this Bishop
can now take and the pawn can't
recapture because there were students
come down here so all-in-all although it
doesn't look like the Queen has to move
the Queen really needs to move we want
the rook to kind of stay here to protect
this pawn here on a b2 and so if we kind
of look at the moves the Queen to d3 is
definitely the best option
it protects this pawn it still protects
this Knight right here and it's kind of
the the more solid choices can it
controls more of the board so that's
what Nakamura does Queen here to d3
we're coming here to d8 just kind of
centralizing the rooks for a vision on
pawn taking here on d5 and then Queen
here to a4 this is one of those move I
thinks it's important to kind of dig a
little deeper into what both players are
thinking because machine on decides not
to just take this material back instead
these kind of just setting all of these
little bitty traps for Nakamura to see
if he'll fall into them and just see if
you can get these slight advantages or
maybe it takes Nakamura an extra 5 10 20
minutes sometimes for a move and
hopefully those little small things can
add up to an advantage later into the
game the reason he doesn't take right
away this chien on is hoping for maybe
pawn takes here on e6 hey I've already
taken upon I'll go ahead and take
another pawn but this is actually gonna
be deadly this Queen here on 84 is
really just attacking this the square
here on D
not even necessarily this rook
particularly because after the bishop
comes here to e6 this opens up the door
for this rook a discovered attack on
this Queen and more importantly a
discovered attack on the square on the
one because this Queen really needs to
move doesn't want to lose this piece but
there's no real good square for this
this Queen to go you know could always
try to protect with pawn here to b3 but
let's say you move your queen you could
come over here a queen here to III then
all of a sudden this risk is gonna come
down here check it's kind of almost
forced to take with your rook here and
then this Queen's gonna come down
all of a sudden whites in a ton of
trouble so just that and that Queen
being right there is it's hugely
valuable if you were to see you know
pawn here to b3 says hey if you're gonna
take my queen I'm gonna take your queen
as well then all of a sudden the Queen
just takes the knight here on a three
and whites down a ton of material as
well so a black knows
hey I'm not gonna take this pawn because
I can take it back and this is kind of
another opportunity for nakamora to make
a mistake now nakamora does not make a
mistake he plays rook up here to d2 this
is kind of one of those other moves if
you're just kind of going through the
match you you wonder is he just kind of
looking for maybe a triple barrel with
the two rooks and the Queen but really
he needs to protect the square here on
d1 doesn't want to give up that
variation that we looked about now we
have pawn here to a b-52 solidifying the
Queen protection right here Luke over
here to d1 getting ready to push forward
with this pawn right here now the pawn
takes does not want that pawn to push up
any further now Bishop taking on d5
center of the board bishop here to see
six now pawn here to e4 and this is
really nice move you could see Bishop
taking here on a c6
after the rook takes we see the rook
take and then the rooks going to take
that's clearly going to be terrible you
don't want to give up your Queen right
there pawn to e4 is really nice play of
using your central pawns and the best
way to have a nice little outpost for
this Bishop here on d5 it's very rare
that on the 20th move is actually when
you
play your pawn on the the e-file for the
first time but Nakamura kind of held on
to it waiting for that moment and now he
is kind of controlling this d5 square
that blacks held on to most of the game
machine aam plays pawn to a6 just
solidifying his pawn chain right here
pawn up here to h4 starting to attack on
the King side Bishop takes here on d5 is
you just have to get rid of the central
bishop right here it's just controlling
the entire board it has nice little
outpost but now after the pawn takes
white now has a passed pawn on board
anytime you have a passed pawn I always
recommend pushing that pawn now Queen
over here to a b4 and then rook to be 1
now if you ask me my vote is I'm always
going to just say pawn here to d6 after
pawn to d6 we can see the bishop take
here on b1 hey wise well just push
forward pawn here to d7 rook here to c7
kind of a forced move Knight over here
to see 2 attacking the Queen the Queen
can just come back here a queen here to
f5 I think nakamora
definitely looked at this if you kind of
saw him studying this position trying to
see if this was gonna be how he wanted
to there's just no real way for white to
do much with this pass pawn right here
just so much material just kind of
blocking this and it's very difficult
for Y to really kind of undo this and
just has to worry about this annoying
Bishop over here so the sides in this
position although I usually like to see
a passed pawn decides to play a room
over here to a b1 does not want to give
up any extra material so Kant wants to
hold on to this pawn here on b2 Queen
here to a 5 and then pawn up here to be
for Queen to a4 is is definitely
interesting this is going to be pretty
tough in my opinion if you kind of look
what machine ons doing you could kind of
get his queen outside decides to go
ahead and keep it in and it's gonna be
difficult for him to get it out can no
longer come to a5 and so nakamora
splaying he has a couple of one is to
kind of push this palm but his secondary
plan is to somehow trap this Queen here
and then eventually capture it
so Nakamura is going to play a rook up
here to b3 trying to give no room for
this Queen to move at all now Bishop
here to e7 threatening this pond right
here recover here to e2 nice little move
kind of one of those hey I kind of
double dare you to take this pawn right
here if the bishop does take then all of
a sudden this rook can come up here to
e4 a pretty dangerous right here can
just take this bishop if the bishop
moves the Queen is going to fall so it
definitely has to worry about that the
rest of the game so after the recover
here to e2 we see a rook to c7 just
protecting this bishop so the roof just
doesn't come up here right away
now King here to g2 there's gonna be a
lot of shenanigans going on the game and
nakamora wants to make sure he doesn't
need to go right now he's in a great
position anons kind of in this place
where there's no great square for him to
go to so you know knocking Morgan kind
of look at this and say I'm gonna go and
protect my king a little bit I don't
want you bringing your rook down here to
c1 at any time have anything crazy
happen so I'm gonna play King to g2 and
kind of just see what you do now we see
vision on play a bishop here to f6 kind
of just dancing around trying to kind of
see what he can maneuver but as Queens
just on the other side of that board
it's not really involved in the action
at all a queen over here to f3 still
holding on to the central pawn here on a
d5 it's important to hold on to that
central pot a rook over here to e7 rook
over here to d2 does not what exchange
of a tear-off wants to kind of use all
these pieces to kind of support this
pond also wants to hold on to his rook
on b3 i doesn't want to use that
anywhere because it's blocking off of
this Queen here on a four row cover here
to a d7 Queen over here to e2 pawn here
to g6 pawn pushing forward to h5 we
could see an exchange on the board in
semi C pawn here to g5 now the Queen's
gonna come over here to d1 I think it's
fine as well to play Knight to a c2
first but decides to go and play Queen
here to a d1 actually protecting this
square here on c2 which we'll see a
little bit later on Bishop back here to
G
vii vision Asha is trying to kind of
hold on here's peaches just are not
really all in sync he doesn't have a
clear path as far as what he's going to
do but not here to see to getting ready
to play rook to a3 that's kind of the
goal of what we're going for
and so after this we see the Queen come
down here to a2 but hey Nakamura says I
don't really care about your queen over
here I've kind of got it on lockdown so
I'm just gonna play a knight over here
to e3 my queen is protecting this rook
here on b3 and I can get my my knight
involved into the game your queen it's
not doing anything it's gonna be very
very hard especially with this rook here
on B 3 so Queen here - a1 trying to say
hey what can I do here let's just go to
exchange Queens off the board kind of
trade down to the very end and see if I
can get a draw out of this the Queen's
gonna come off the board the bishops
gonna come off the board
we're over here - ay - swing - Bishop
back here Knight here to f5 Nakamura
says yeah you trade it off but I really
like my position on board now Bishop
over here - g7 rook up here taking on a
six kind of getting that pawn back that
was taken off the board here on a -
Bishop back here - f8 and this is
actually a pretty nice place if you
haven't gone through this game already
just kind of stop and see how you would
proceed with Nakamura this is something
I may add to my site later as far as I
practice I think it's a really good
position it's kind of look at to
evaluate how you should proceed I think
there's one clearly a best move here and
that's what Nakamura place because he's
really good at chess but he plays pawn
here to d6 and really just putting a lot
of pressure that the rook right here
plays a big role into it but if you kind
of look at and say well okay the bishop
could just take but after the bishop
takes then all of a sudden the knight
comes here to h6 check the king is kind
of forced to move now the night down
here - a g4 and this is threatening
Knight here to f6 and that's just kind
of too deadly for vichy not to deal with
he knows he's going to end up lose
massive material here in the endgame is
just gonna be too easy for Nakamura so
in this position machine on decides to
go ahead and resign so really good game
by Nakamura I thought fishing on through
a lot of crazy things that are at
Nakamura a Nakamura responded
beautifully he found all the correct
permutations and some of the traps that
were set by Vichy and on vision honor I
really appreciate the fact that he went
for it there were a lot of places where
he could have gone in safe mode and
could have just gone for a complete draw
but instead he was playing for the win
he gave us an exciting match Nakamura on
the flip side played extremely well
finished the game as he should have kind
of trapped the Queen over here and from
there was a bird to recognize that hey I
need to get my knight involved so what's
the the best and cleanest way to get
that involved and that's exactly what he
did I'm at the end of the day he gets to
victory so he's kind of in commanding
leads go ahead and take this entire
grand chest tour excited to see over the
next week or so if he can kind of close
that out but hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video and I'll see you guys in
round 5 thanks for watching